les mains 30 à peine il y a quinze mois
nadège lascols a subi une opération pour
être électro stimuler mais il y a dix
sept ans elle se rend compte que quelque
chose ne va pas elle a 48 ans j'avais
dans l'avant bras droit
comment dire est
une vibration permanente je veux pas
parler tremblements mais c'était tout de
même dérangeant et
j'ai mis ça sur le dos de la fatigue
c'est une amie et collègue marié un
médecin qui lui prend rendez vous avec
un neurologue qui diagnostique la
maladie après l'annonce des moments
difficiles puis l'acceptation avec son
époux on a réuni les quatre enfants leur
a dit bon
on va on va vous tenir au courant on va
se battre tous ensemble
contre ça c'est une horreur c'est vrai
mais bon on n'y peut rien va être unie
et on va y arriver en fait sans doute un
peu plus aujourd'hui qu'avant sur dans
la maison d'un parce que bon allez
fatigué donc je prends un peu plus
mais pour l'instant j'ai une histoire
mais je connais bien des cas où ce
qu'on appelle les dents je sais comment
on épouse aime pas beaucoup ce terme au
lard elle parle plutôt du terme et
manquent aidant au début c'est pas c'est
pas énorme on arrive
j'ai pu vivre quelques temps presque
normalement
c'était que je travaillais à plein temps
et au début mes collègues ont vu que je
fatigue et un petit peu donc les monts
primé services de récréation c'est tout
mais ça suffisait largement
et puis après
ça va plus bien
on se prend à mi temps et après le mi
temps ne suffit même plus
là il faut bien bien songé à s'arrêter
quoi l'ennemi juré du parkinsoniens doit
être le fauteuil voilà il faut le fuir
il faut bouger il faut vraiment vraiment
être loin nadège et son mari se bat
contre cette maladie au sein
d'associations philippe et délégué
départemental de france parkinson